[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blake
il adore jeu-là d'or il le fait c'est
que je te trouve très très beau merci et
ça lui va bien mais là on dirait
vraiment un joueur vif et nous nous mais
ça on est ridicules nommer les frais tu
leur fais rentrer sur le terrain tu vois
rien lui des bains de soleil il est pur
mais ça vous va bien ce petit train
jaune ses murs et et il a fait un truc
il a fait un truc sais pas j'aime bien
le trait assez le 13 0 et battu c'est
quoi je suis en projet d'un trait c'est
vrai je te jure que vous je suis à toi
je suis en projet d'un trait si tu veux
être comme le nous attestons pense ça
lui irait bien à grains tenons ayrault
s'est fait non je vais faire un trait
est tu fais je le fais